hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen wir befinden
uns ja darum strahlen
wir glauben dass ein bisschen sonne
direkt dahinter ist die sehr guten
körper so dass hier sehr gut weiter so
ich stehe heute nicht alle sondern
er wird okay alles gut wir machen heute
einige kennen zwar die desi penalty
challenge das ist quasi das man so in
dem zustand besoffen fußballspiel
natürlich sind nicht betroffen weil wir
ja alle keinen alkohol konsumieren jetzt
bleibt quasi so ab wir haben hier unten
ein wal gepackt unserer hand drauf
laufen quasi und warum irgendwie acht
bis zehn mal und dann versuchen wir
mitnehmen bald das tor zu treffen
okay okay
magst warum es eigentlich nicht
mitmachen ich mit mir wird es nicht
schlecht wird von den ganzen dingen
wir fangen jetzt an jeder schiesst quasi
dreimal beschießen abwechselnd der
verlierer bekommt anschließend von allen
sitzen fallen dir sitzen wo mein gott oh
ja
12 13
ein paar sekunden später könnte den
leuten sagen darf 15
doch sowohl
herzlichen glückwunsch disqualifizierung
für lucca so passiert geworden wir
machen jetzt bestrafung verlust ein
meter schießt aus zwei metern und ihrer
mensch darf sich vor dreimal drehen darf
nur noch verarscht
das war nicht wirklich gut durchdacht
und gut gehalten
hofer kripo
wir hatten hier zu beginn vier leute
sitzen und jetzt
auf welche seite war da die meisten
hören ja
er sitzt für fände vom video wendet euch
gefallen hat lacht gerne ein leichter
wenn jetzt noch mal stehen bald auch
einen doppelten und beim fünften mal
mache ich sonst chef